okay come on in that's my car
[Music]
[Music]
it's great to be here so I will talk
about scaling test pad and let me go
ahead and say this so at some level
integration
there's aspect of understanding your
price technologies work or they don't
work in different settings I think the
message here is going to be mixed yes
they apply in a variety of different
settings that I will talk about but can
they improve the answer is absolutely
yes I think the more interesting part of
the talk from my perspective is that if
we start so this is a system level talk
but integrating technologies into a
system and the key aspect I want to sort
of drive out and tease out a little bit
more is that if we integrate this
technology into the systems some new
challenges and new approaches come
around so there are some interesting
challenges which probably one may not
have experienced or seen before which
sort of pop out when you sort of try
this integration so that's why I'm
hoping what that to achieve let's see
how that goes so let me first give you a
bit of an introduction on IOT IOT is
ubiquitous it's almost in every domain
as when devices and everything that you
carry your mobile phones are connected
to the Internet or a network you have an
opportunity of sort of creating systems
you're smart intelligent adaptive which
can observe the phenomena or what's
going on in the real world and obviously
use that to improve basically processes
that go on as well as to bring new
functionalities this is the next
dominant wave probably which will maybe
even dwarf the internet revolution that
happened the expectation is very large
so they were already over 25 billion
devices are connected today and this
connection will continue on and on the
expectation is that very very large
amounts of data will be
generated from these different domains
these IOT domains are based around
sensors so sensors capture data about
the environment which obviously if there
are humans in the environment then
you're going to have privacy issues that
come in as well the particular IOT
setting which I will be sort of
migrating towards sort of talk to mostly
about is more towards building
management or space smart spaces such as
this room itself there's video cameras
all around so in some sense you are
observing or you're also already sensing
what's going on in this environment so
there will be the focus to that we sort
of use in the stuff so this is the
concept of testbed that we started off
with the help of DARPA and the idea was
to take physical spaces instrument
sensors in it and build the systems
within data gets generated from these
different sensors it passes through a
system we do data management of the
sensor data then we build applications
and services on top of this particular
system that we have and we actually have
real users use these services in real
time in whatever in their daily activity
and the goal was in this setting was the
system that we build will infuse in it
diverse pricey enhancing technologies
and we'll talk about specifically what
we have done in a couple of minutes and
the thought then was that if I take
these different privacy enhancing
technologies I can evaluate whether it's
good or not good or how effective it is
so this is a technology evaluation
aspect to it one can even sort of
understand user studies and say okay
what do people perceive what because
they're using these applications in the
context of let's say a system of this
kind of desperate of this kind so you
can even the user studies see what
people's perception over privacy might
be and as I already mentioned the
interesting part from my perspective and
from our perspective was research caps
so there is one thing which is there's a
lot of work which if sort of morning
we've been seeing it and I guess last
two days has been seeing a lot of
interesting sort of work that's
happening in the price.you domain the
question is if I integrate this into a
system what actually happens and are
there other issues that come around so
that's sort of what we're after
so here's the outline of the talk what
I'll do is it'll be sort of a bird's-eye
view for talk I'll talk a little bit
about different system to give you the
context of what we are doing in the
context of and they're also a little bit
of the testbed that we have at UCI we
look into privacy leakage from sensors
it should be relatively straightforward
to sort of see the sensors which observe
people at very fine-grain have a
significant amount of information
captured about humans that leads to
price the inferences that can be made so
we have done a preliminary study of what
the leakages and it actually relates
that to some degree to lease talk as
well because she talked about
trajectories and she talked about
basically the mobility patterns of
people so some relationship in that
sense to that this particular time only
thing as well they'll be look into the
challenges in deploying the privacy
technologies the campus scale
specifically we look into scalability as
challenge so then we first start with
telling a little bit about tippers
so tippers is sort of the heart the
system is the heart of the test but
itself it's the thing that does your
data management it gets information from
diverse sensors which flows in and we do
representation of this data now the wave
you designed the system from a system
perspective is it's a middle way
approach so we get the data we process
it we model lay it be represented but
then we want to store it we send it off
to its Storage Manager which is
typically either Oracle or my sequel or
other systems that we will see which are
maybe secure computation systems as well
so we do that the architecture of the
system is plug in play so the whole idea
behind this was that will develop a
plug-and-play a technology where you can
bring in different diverse price
technologies integrate them inside
we don't necessarily develop all these
things ourselves but we sort of borrow
from a lot of people actually a lot of
people in this room itself as well and
specifically all right so before we go
into the pricey technologies so the
triple system has been built and it has
been deployed in a different places the
it started off with being deployed in
the building then with the computer
science building at UCI which is the
brain hall and slowly it has sort of
migrated towards or increased to about
35 buildings now we get data from 35
different building
and sort of we have building services on
top of this 35 different things the
buildings and there are a variety of
different services which he and I'll
show you a couple of more examples of
that these services range from real time
services location-based services to
analysis for building analysis kind of
services as well so a lot of these
different kinds of services are built on
top of essentially the campus testbed
the people system also was ported and
installed at Honeywell Gordon their lab
and we're the what they did was they
were trying to understand individual
behavior from shared sensor data and
specifically they connected tippers to
about 2,000 motion sensors which are in
their building and the data flowed from
that to tippers and they were let's say
services on top of that then they were
building it's also more recently going
on to speak or move then in the
installation at SPAWAR in San Diego
where they have connected a variety of
different other sensors like active
badges Bluetooth combined with and
they've taken this data that they sort
of generate along with simulated data as
well which we have which we generate for
them for their particular let's say
installation and the gold theorist race
Explorer a slightly different twist
which actually I will not talk about
today too much because there's ongoing
work at this stage which is on building
monitoring services based on privacy so
this is I the the the people mobile and
start of installation towards not about
let's say data release or sharing of
data to others but really building
monitoring services real-time monitoring
services using privacy technologies talk
a little bit more about because the
context let's talk is going to be UCI
testbed so let me talk a little bit more
about the installation we have there so
do you see why we have variety of
different sensors ranging from Bluetooth
beacons video cameras power monitoring
systems and most importantly the Wi-Fi
access point eight assets so one of the
advantages of Wi-Fi access point dataset
is that if I sort of look at your
connectivity data from the Wi-Fi access
point I do not need to install any
software on your machine so it's a
passive sort of a monitoring device well
I can sort of get a relatively
inaccurate but at some level still
localization information coming from the
access point which can
get you within a particular region where
the access point is sort of there now
this information coupled with other
information can actually provide that
we've seen and we've sort of looked at
that significantly more accurate let's
say localization with buildings itself
the advantage being that I don't have to
install anything at all to sort of
monitor people in this case so in other
words you can monitor thousands and
people as we will see basically without
any installation of technology and their
phones are asking them to do anything
else different at all so we get this
data and this data is pretty sensitive
so naturally it is encrypted before it's
given to us there is a mechanism which
sort of enables dipper's to go back to
if for example you want to use not
general services but let's say you want
to use location-based services for your
own then you have to give us explicit
consent and then we'll go back to
essentially the the UCI level let's say
where the data is collected and given
show us your credentials to get actually
data about you so we can open the data
that you that it's sort of relates to
you so we can offer you more higher
level services so when data flows in
from different sensors there are the
main things we do is we create a dynamic
map of where people are as a function of
time and based on your location the data
or the plesance we sort of convert that
into occupancy which is then at the
spatial level so in this room there are
hundred people in that room there are 50
people or an inner officer whether you
are there or not for instance so then
that becomes occupancy as I said we
started with something which is in a
single building now it's expanded and
the interesting part from here which
will be important later in the talk
is if you sort of look at the datasets
we are talking of roughly around a
million events a day location events a
day so we want to be able to scale
pricey technologies when we sort of
implement them in this context of
something like this to adhere to or to
be able to sort of tolerate that levels
of workload and then there are
applications built on top so in example
an application is a concierge
application where you come into the
building you want to find me you can
sort of if I've given you permission
then you can track me in real time you
can also track which rooms are empty
where you want to sort of you order can
do building analytics all that is
different as you know
imagine a variety of different services
and one thing I should add is that once
we build the system we open the
interface gave it the students to go
crazy on it and they build lots and lots
of different applications which is sort
of on top of this data okay so from
privacy technology perspective tipples
has a variety of things integrated
inside it it has fine-grained policy
basically which controls who has access
to what data I'll talk a little bit more
about that there is secure data
management which is Vinh data comes in
papers it's encrypted
at least the wife access point data so
then the security management data from
papers can go into the cloud
again we use security management for
that purpose this differential privacy
we'll talk about that in a second
actually the people who did that work is
also here zero much pain and my crew
they're the yes they're the guys who
sort of implemented differential privacy
we took their work and incorporate into
our system and then there's also
resource discovery so policies are
integral to tippers it's all the way
from the hole every processing of data
is based on policies so what data gets
collected and let me see if this works
what data gets collected what data gets
stored how long is it stored for what
processing is allowed on it or who can
share that data with whom everything to
hold this is a data cycle
enterprise is controlled through
essentially policies but differential
privacy the place it's integrated is in
the occupancy so we have the pure
occupancy that we have calculated from
the let's say the present data once we
have a sensor data once we have that if
we want to expose this privacy to others
or this sorry this occupancy to others
we sort of run into a differential
privacy algorithm the specific
everything we sort of integrated is
system called Pegasus which was built by
the guys I mentioned to you earlier so
we sort of integrate that as well again
dippers has when data comes in into the
system it can be outsourced the
outsourced data can be in a encrypted
form so there are multiple different
let's the database systems which have
been integral database systems that have
been degraded one of them is pulsar
each in the other one is Jana by Galois
these all these systems support a
variety of different cryptographic
mechanisms so for example pulsar has
function secret sharing it also a search
for encryption built in
and so on Gina is sort of interesting in
the sense that it supports full-blown
SQL the SQL queries on encrypted domain
it offers a variety of different sliding
scale security so you can store data in
a pure in a in a in a plain text form
you can also use MPC engine which is
when they built on top of the speech
engine as well so you can do MPC
computation as well so you sort of get a
variety of different let's say
technologies with these things okay so
that's sort of enough as a background
for what tapers is let me go into a
little bit more to inferences from
sensor data so when we started the
project the very first thing we sort of
did was we went to UCI and got them to
give us five access point data sets and
the question then that came up was that
the the university would not give you
the Wi-Fi access point and said unless
it is anonymized so it is anonymize data
now for this crowd this will be
absolutely no issue at all an
organization doesn't basically work and
one of the obvious things is they could
reconstruct from it basically when the
people start arriving then they do not
arrive when the day ends and all that
stuff more interesting thing is even
simple very simple classification
techniques based on your patterns of
let's say use or what you do in the
building sort of can completely identify
if you're a visitor for example if your
visitor then you connect with a 1x
access point then you go away if you are
a resident you probably you are there
for a longer time so all these things
sort of can be done so classification of
people into grad students students
faculty staff all that stuff is
relatively simple even straightforward
sequel queries which is what we ended up
writing could classify them and get a
calculus level around 98% or so so we
didn't even have to train very complex
models at all for this purpose and once
you have classification you can do
social media and I'll Dec social group
analysis who meets who that kind of
stuff the question which came up at that
time was why is this interesting why is
this important and here a couple of
examples of why it's important for
instance once I can track staff I can
figure out who spends how much time
inside there so the top graph is sort of
showing a histogram of how many hours
people spend and how many of them are
sort of how many faculty spent how many
stuffs and how much time this can get
sensitive here is the one which I serve
particularly because
is me so we also did another thing just
to drive home the point of the to the
people so we sort of took the once I
have triangulated and figured out that
this person is a faculty and if I know
the class schedule then I sort of know
when the faculty shows up in this
particular person shows up in that room
that that's that faculty member once I
have that information I can start
plotting things like hey how often are
you late to your class and that's what
the graph is showing the red means
tardiness and green sharing good it's
okay
so you can see that there's this guy in
the middle of who's sort of is very
often hardy for example so you can do
all the interesting stuff it's sort of
during the home the point that there is
interesting privacy questions which you
may even in a new quest data such as hey
location said building in our campus
perspective is actually is a huge amount
of privacy questions which come up this
is a study that was done by Honeywell to
drive essentially similar points I'm not
going to belabor too much basically they
had the the reason why there are
differences that in our case Wi-Fi
access point data sets are very personal
it's like one person like it's my data
my connectivity information even though
it's anonymizes about me here it's about
motion sensors just sort of installed
all over the building and the thing that
shows was that if you take some
information about basically people and
their practices using motion sensitive
that you can actually pretty much figure
out who's not coming a particular day
who's coming per today that's the things
you under the top figure the part which
is sort of interesting is the lower one
this is a one specific motion sensor
data and there's a particular pattern to
it if you notice there is hey there is a
time period which somebody is there the
motion sensor is on and then it's off
then on then on this repeated pattern so
I don't know if anybody can guess but
that could imply
smoking there you go it's exactly
smoking its exact looking pattern so you
pretty much know how much did the guys
smoke it's a real data
the guy had agreed to sell shares data
with us it can be determined so that was
a study on motion sensor the third study
which is the UCI part of the study is
more towards differential privacy so
what we did was we had occupancy data
and I said earlier we took Pegasus sort
of virtual they were Pegasus system and
we generated differential private
occupancy data on top of it the question
we are going to ask was given that I
have access to a occupancy data how
accurately can I now localize people or
individuals based on this occupancy data
so the first question was before we will
study something like this we have to
have a notion of utility because
obviously I can just random noise and
then everything will be totally private
right so that wouldn't that's not the
right thing so we chose a particular
application which is the heat map of
occupancy and what we did was we sort of
said okay there are going to be five
colors in this heat map so green all the
way to red showing the amount of people
in particular that's a location okay and
if I sort of look at their five colors
if I were to randomly guess it'll be 20%
chance I'm going to get it correct so
the expectation is that without any data
whatsoever without many priors without
any knowledge at all I sort of get 20%
correctness anyway the question was
let's set a bar for differential privacy
to be a little bit when I'm releasing it
to a little bit higher from application
utility perspective so the experiment
with a few things I don't know if the
next graph to show that or not but we
decided to be not particularly this
[Music]
aggressive about this matter so you just
said okay let's make sure that we get
the utility of around 40% so I want to
set a threshold of epsilon to a
differential privacy such that the
utility at every instance of time
remains around 40% or so and this turned
out from identity I have the graph right
here so that turns out that if you want
that the epsilon that I required in this
case was at least one now that being
said it's possible that I could have
taken a system such as Pegasus and could
have trained it much better or whatever
done a little bit more post analysis
then we did to get higher the utility
that's a possibility but we didn't try
that hard we did try a little bit but
not that hard
so he said epsilon equals one so the
question that vmf was alright how much
is now the privacy loss how much can if
I output the location later at the
epsilon equals one what will be the
location basically to what level can I
guess person's location for this
particular experiment what we did was we
took about one month of differentially
private occupancy data from UCI from our
Grand Hall and there are that many
regions so another question which I came
early and leafstalk as well was the
granularity aspect so the question is
localization of people to what level
that the level of the building at the
level of a floor region or maybe room
and so that's why it's important there
are six floors in the building there 23
regions and 334 rooms so those are the
number of events that happen
the methodology be used as the following
we sort of took the top 50 people who
come to the building and we sort of
looked into the privacy or basic ability
for us to guess the location of these
top 50 people out of 21,000 people now
the reason we sort of did this was
because the models that we're running
behind the scene are very complex and
sort of a traditionally extensive so we
had to choose something we chose the top
50 yes
so the epsilon that you're you're
writing here is that is that for the
epsilon using for us a single occupancy
count or is that a person level epsilon
no in this case it's for the single leg
it's actually it's actually the system
generated using Pegasus so Pegasus is
sliding window kind of a thing so it
takes a window and it publishes it for a
particular window and we buried the
epsilon to variety of different levels
we have the data set right so we have
the data set for oops sorry where'd it
go yeah one one difference should be I
did right so before we have different we
also have the actual data as well so we
could figure out who are the top 50 guys
were sort of in the building looking at
the real data so I know that there is a
grind cuz I'm looking at your
connectivity information so I know that
you are occupying the most amount of
time in that in that one month so I have
actual data as well right there for the
analysis we sort of used both the actual
as well as the different private one
okay all right results I guess okay
before you do that so the the main
question obviously in any model of this
kind is what's the prior so we did not
use a particularly strong prior in this
particular case the prior is based on
transition probabilities which is again
learn basically on the data itself
we did not customize the way Li was
trying to do for individuals the prior
is sort of a global model basically for
everybody
so so it's time invariant in two digit
individual invariant and perhaps can be
improved there is a lot of work going on
sort of trying to improve the prize
itself and for the posterior probability
there are multiple different techniques
people used but the one set of which I'm
reporting here is the using particle
filtering so we sort of pushed this into
the particle filtering set of a system
and out came the output problem the
probability of a person's location now
there are multiple different studies we
did but the one I'm sort of going to
show the result on is an aggregated
privacy metric and the way we did this
was the following thing how many given a
granularity
let's explore that whatever it is at
this linearity if I look at the
probability P based on the occupancy
statistics which is the at a given
probability level the probability level
is divided into low medium and high so
how many extra people do I get to know
them as a given level which I could not
based on priors so if a prior already
gave me information about you so for
example if you're a printer and not a
human being so you're always in the
building the prior tells it to me
already right you're not moving
hopefully right so then I already know
that so that's not counted right so I'm
looking for how many extra things do I
get to learn based on the differential
prior data which the prior would not
actually offer to me and the results
were sort of here so out of the 50
people if you remember the green is
showing then of those 50 people during
the time period how many over there in
the real building the red is showing
what are the extra people we could get
to know at medium probability and the
purple is showing at the high
probability and what you get to see
those numbers don't show up that clearly
in the figure is out of the 50 about
four or five people's private like
location was sort of known to us based
on the model we had based on epsilon
equals one in this case I think the main
point of the study was that yes privacy
is a challenge and there is a groom for
sort of improving things okay so I'm
going to push through the third part of
my talk which is in challenges in
deploying privacy technologies at campus
scale
so if I look at deployment of pricey
technologies and for us the price of
technologies are not just differential
privacy in fact today I'm not going to
talk much about differential privacy
it's also secure computation it's also
policy management and the question is
what are the challenges that come when
you try to do any of these things first
question that lab that shows up is the
scalability challenge and the question
is given the scale of data and queries
can you actually could scale the secure
computing technology to that level and
we will see a little bit of work on that
direction similarly for policies policy
in the IOT spaces are going to be very
fine-grained and if you're fine grained
policies can today's database systems
which do support policy management of
policy engines can they actually do
real-time enforcement and likewise from
the differential privacy perspective
given the application that are asking
complex queries can you do this in a
meaningful way while still ensuring some
level of privacy of people so you sort
of made a little bit of progress in each
of these different things the last one
is sort of collaboration with our
Schwinns group which is on one side
differential privacy and I'll maybe
refer to it nominate and maybe if not
you'll see all right the second
challenge is also equally important is
that interoperability it's not about
scalability but interoperability so
specifically you take differential
privacy the question that we have is
that what should that Cilan be that's
the interoperability question how do you
explain let's say an absolute the person
right so there'll be a interoperability
question in this case of explained
pricey budget and similarly you have
data sets different data sets at
different levels of security
requirements or different levels of
inferences how do you build secure
mediation around something like that so
give you a little bit of scale here is
the data sets for which I sort of talked
about earlier already so if you look at
let's say you see a data set that we
have generated even for one building via
approximately two seconds two events per
second that arises arises which is
around 44,000 events per day if you take
a campus level set of installation which
is let's say roughly two like Berkeley
but also at least one 200 buildings if
you sort of take that we're talking or
something around 500 events per second
so here sort of getting this much data
in and you are trying to build real time
services after ensuring privacy
technologies inside it and similarly the
query is there a mix of selections
aggregation and joint queries
in DBH for the time and we are running
the services we roughly get about 10 API
calls per minute so that's the set of
amount of usage now we have not
publicized the stuff too much as the
thing scales and goes over the campus
level this will probably increase a lot
more so the question for us first was
can be designed secure data management
technology that can sustain such query
and data rates so go back to secure
computing there's a lot of work in
secure computing that's happened and if
you look at it ranging from home African
Krypton techniques or M techniques to a
deterministic encryption do not like
order present encryption and so on
there's a lot of work which is to adhere
it towards practical let's say security
and the problem with that is that
actually leaks a lot of information if
you go towards something which is much
more secure for example form of
encryption with no RAM the speeds of
this are much much much slower their
orders several orders of magnitude sort
of too slow there's more recent work on
secret sharing mechanisms and MPC based
systems which offer also very strong
security guarantees but they're also
incredibly slow several orders magnitude
slow so this will give you a sense the
second column there refers to the time
and when I say sometimes X that means
that the technology takes that much
overhead compared to let's say plaintext
processing so the specifically
interesting part of it here is if you
look at home off at let's say
multi-party compute MPC sort of engines
they are probably around a million times
slower it which is several or five or
six orders of magnitude slower compared
to plain text processing right now and
if you sort of compare this to a
strategy in which I have let's say about
shows data and stored somewhere else and
we just have download the whole data
instead of compute on the downloaded
data that is roughly around 10,000 times
worse so these techniques are sort of
much worse than a full retrieval of data
sets itself so the key inside that we
went after in terms of building or
scaling technologies then this applies
both for secure computing which I will
talk about now and also for differential
privacy as well was exploiting partials
video data so if I sort of look at data
itself and the building data think of
let's say entry exit data from a
building going back to the example which
has said that there's influence about
people number ours their work
that probably is sensitive because I can
infer something which is useful from the
data but if I sort of am inside the
building right now the specific location
I'm at probably is not that sensitive
unless of course in a sensitive room are
smoking lounge then sensitive again but
a lot of the data that you sort of deal
with is actually not sensitive at all so
in that particular case in terms of
let's say you want to hide their
teaching schedule Affairs right so the
time when you enter into the teaching
room that instance or time might be
sensitive but if I'm sitting in my
office that's really not sensitive the
part that I'm in the building is
sensitive when I enter the building and
I leave the building that's probably
sensitive so you can always take these
data sets and sort of come up with
strategies on figuring out what
sensitive nodes not sensitive
similarly examples with surveillance
video surveillance video cameras are
there all the places not sensitive but
if unless somebody objects so for
example I just signed a consent saying
here you can tape this thing today so
it's not sensitive had I not done that
even if the taping was going on that
would be sensitive so basically the key
insight is you can sort of take data
sets of this kind and decide sensitivity
non sensitivity and this is not a new
idea this is sort of if you go back to
the practice of privacy and security
that's sort of very commonly implied so
the question that we had was can be
exploit this to improve performance so
let me give you an example so let's take
the example from the perspective of
computing of secure computation so here
is an example of secure computation
where we have let's say partly
sensitively and partly non sensitive
data and I've divided up into two parts
now most of the data I'm assuming going
to be nonsense tape some part of the
data is going to be sensitive and
there's a query queue which I run so the
query will naturally get partitioned
into parts they'll be quit running and
thirstier they'll be query on
non-sensitive and you'll can collect the
answers from both them and construct the
answer obviously this leaks information
so here's an example of it leaks for
example if I retrieve tt-to from the
sensitive side and that ability in the
in the case of in this case I'm looking
for John's record t6 from non sensitive
side the adversely has learned the t26
correspond to the same guy so hey t 2 is
actually John's record you know that ok
what if I use a technique which is
access pattern hiding so most a large
number of techniques are expert in
heading we are expensive but do you pay
the price but the sort of it can be done
what do you learn we still done the same
do you learn that there exists a record
from the output size you learn the thing
that they hey John has a sensitive
record for example so the question is
what's the security guarantee you want
so one way you can sort of look at this
is imagine I've got this world in which
they're sensitive and not sensitive data
what I'm trying to avoid is link ability
between sensitive and nonsense relator I
don't want there to be linked to each
other and furthermore I don't want
basically the cypher today I would want
the effort X in this English abilities I
want favorite X to be distinguished not
indistinguishable from each other so
that sort of you can formalize this
property so let's now look at the same
thing and try to achieve a ciphertext
extinguish ability and also non link
ability properties so here's an example
so imagine I have what I have done now
is I've changed the problem
instead of sort of looking at the data
it's sensitive nonsense state in itself
I'm going to actually bring them
together I'm going to create a sort of
partition of boots and Steven on send
data into bins and when a query comes in
instead of a tree for a query Q instead
of sort of retrieving one object or one
particular bin sorry one particular data
object or a particular value I'm going
to retrieve all the objects in a given
bin which is sort of there's a cesta bin
there's non-sensitive and I'm going to
retrieve both them okay so at this stage
what does address relearn that verse he
learns that hey there is something
between these two there's some
connection between these two bins
there's something that exists which
enables you to sort of retrieve a
sensitive bin and also an ancestor bit
but if you do this work a little bit
carefully what you can do is you can
ensure that every sensitive Bend is
collected every non-sensitive bin if you
actually achieve a complete sort of a
bipartite graph in this particular case
what you get is that Leslie will not be
able to learn any Association
specifically between objects at the
object level though he even if he learns
that a given bin and two bins they
connect the retrieve at the same time
you don't really get actually the fact
that if every bin is possibly connected
to every possible bin then there really
will not learn anything at all so this
technique would be can be shown to be
essentially it would not leak any
information through our joint access or
through output size attacks though there
are some challenges in workflow in
workload skew attacks which can sort of
happen but you can even overcome that so
let me I'm going to run out of time so I
probably will not be able to give you
the algorithm as to how to achieve such
a pian so let me skip past that but let
me show you a quick result so here's a
result so very simple idea from a system
perspective or binning things instead of
retrieving them together question is how
well does it work now in this bin if you
notice what I've done is instead of
treating one object I'm retrieving
multiple different objects basically
trying to hide the access pattern or
association between accesses very very
different people so if you sort of
develop a cost model for it what turns
out finally is a result right here where
if your sensitivity is alpha the
percentage of sensitive data is alpha if
this is less than and this gamma is the
time it takes to encrypt something
released sorry to transmit one record on
a network was divided by the amount of
time it takes for encryption so if you
take that gamma and and there's also
square root of NS which is number of
sensitive bills that you create so this
value typically is expected to be very
small so for most amount of let's say
alpha values which are the amount
sensitivity of data unless this is
treated as or 99% data is sensitive this
approach will actually work very well
and it will perform better from
analytical perspective we can sort of
show that and here's a real result from
basically running experiments on on the
of the technique on two different
techniques or two different approaches
so one was be applied a SGX based sort
of a hard whatever in execute
computation we applied query bending on
top of it we also took a npc engine and
trap like very bidding on it and we can
significantly improve the performance
the interesting part is not just that
that the performance improves
significantly it's also that the query
be named because access patterns are
hidden and output attack is hidden these
techniques become more secure as well
the experimental results let me skip it
the there are a lot of assumptions that
we sort of made but about how to query
being technique will work within the
people sort of relaxes all that stuff
let me give you one more thing and then
we will be done with it so that's this
is the pitch for the differential
privacy part again so we used
sensitivity of data or nonsense to be
the data of a partial sense ability to
sort of improve on the performance of
secure computing the same idea can be
carried over to also differential
privacy so here is an example so imagine
again the occupancy data that we had and
the query that I want to ask is how many
events will occupancy over twenty happen
on this particular day so this is a real
result basically real data which is
coming in and you what you have to count
is number of events which are which have
occupancy of more than 20 now if I look
at this data set this differential
parity decide with Pegasus with in this
particular case of Sal Nichols point one
it's very difficult to sort of get this
answer the real data is this this is the
real data
so the question is if you lose
differential privacy and maybe you can't
design specific divisions pricey
techniques for this particular partner
for this particular question but the
utility of these queries sort of these
techniques sort of for answering these
queries goes away as the complexity of
query increases the utility actually
goes very bad so what could we do so
again what we're going to do is exploit
sensitivity so I'll give you an example
and then leb with that
so imagine datasets at this stage can be
partitioned into sensitive and non
sensitivity parts so some data is
sensitive some data is not restive
usually this is based on a policy okay
so if is one possibility is let me just
go ahead when a query comes in let me
give you the results on the non
sensitive part as is and use
differential privacy for basically
sensitive parts but if you do that what
you can show is that you can actually
need to leakage as well so what we did
with the help of our schwinn and ESO
serves the students that were sitting
there so we ended up defining this
generalizing this concept of deficient
of differential privacy to basically
one-sided differential privacy and the
idea was that since I have got data
which is both sensitive and non
sensitive
amad imagine the whole goal is to hide
and provide guarantees to only the
sensitive data and not to the non
sensitive data so if something is
sensitive we want to ensure that that
remains the the I released the nonsense
data in such a way that the fact that a
particular data is not released causes a
confusion or remains the ensures
uncertainty whether the data was not
released because it was sensitive or
because we just did not do it because
the mechanism sort of did not do it so
again we can do this he was a I'm not
showing results of it because his work
is sort of in progress in submission but
here's the interesting aside for this
notion of one side privacy so in this
one side privacy they'd able to sort of
publish not just necessarily the
differential prior data or count data
but you can actually since we had
started publishing potentially since the
nonsense data in its raw form there is a
whole new set of application that can
potentially build around this so imagine
let's say I've got video data or any
kind of let's say
multimodal data or even text data and I
want to sort of provide guarantees
strong privacy guarantees by sharing
this data so I can actually using the OS
DP allistic mechanism share parts of the
real data without with while still
maintaining essentially strong
guarantees so I can actually do things
like summarization I can say the
extractor some of the summaries
publishing multimedia data using this
technique alright so I'm going to skip
that and go straight to the conclusions
which is right here the conclusion is
that we have a system which we built the
main message which I wanted to bring out
was that as we integrate different
technologies new challenges arise and
new significant body of work which is
sort of done if you multi-level security
for example the time when this this
clearances were sort of coming over
people coming with is not a little
security stuff right then a similar kind
of question that came up as well and so
there are a lot of work that's been done
in trying to automate this process of
selecting what sensitive and what's not
sensitive I don't think it has succeeded
in all cases there are certain
situations maybe people can apply some
some techniques for example so this give
you a trivial idea in the mind please
imagine that this data which is class
schedule is published on the web hey
that cannot possibly be sensitive for
sure whereas if you have in if you have
access control policies just dictate
that hey some parts of people people
object to say in sharing some data you
can
lies there to sort of learn sales videos
not sensitivity in this case so people
have tried different things but it's a
good question I don't think there is a
clear-cut 100 percent answer to that
particular question basically the the
issue can be pushed around from the
other perspective as well so I have to
build a system I required a sort of
published data for this system that's
why it's a little different computer
let's say a traditional Census Bureau
kind of situation where you publish data
with privacy sacrosanct here a system
must exist so I'm trying to do
monitoring or I'm trying to control for
example it's not the point is you can
get it wrong that's true that's correct
that's correct if you don't have a great
solution so if that's what is saying yes
deeper inside from nothing so in a lot
of ways if you think about it the reason
of the confidence comes from the fact
that this is an Aquos data we have the
data it's not that you can do anything
about it like you want Wi-Fi
connectivity you are connecting I know
where you are
so it's already there the question is
when I share it can I share it a little
bit more wisely that's all
I presented results earlier about
predicting some on this location yep
using the use model and the differently
private I didn't catch weather what was
the comparative like if you didn't use
the differential pressure carding
statistics at all III didn't show that
deal III didn't show that daily yeah yes
so do this that's there right so for two
parts there right because you can sort
of look at from privacy lost perspective
like what if I gave you the exact counts
right I think this question was asked
earlier so like if I give you the exact
counts how much would you have been able
to guess so from that there's a privacy
gain hey if I give you differentially
private stuff
how much do I gain and the loss is a
from the prior difference to prior to
basically the differential private one
right so turns out that the thing I
showed you was around three or four P
out of the fifty about three or more
people I could get to know the location
which priors would not let me know
priors worked well for about if I
remember correctly for about two or
three people so from two it went to four
or five with the Sun equals one and so
the other part is also how much loss was
so from the top if I just give you
counts it was more like if you remember
correctly around ten or so so there's
some gain from privacy
okay
[Applause]